here we got a beautiful right here fella
what's this
yo theo brendan the whole gang it's your
boy tristan colin from atlanta georgia
what's up tristan
um i'm currently on day nine of
quarantine i caught the old covid
uh i actually caught out in nashville so
theo be safe my boy
um but during my down time i i started
revisiting some old
episodes of in living color which made
me think of
today's debate club now do you guys like
that
in living color hitter or that [ __ ]
overrated
snl [ __ ] you guys let me know gang
gang buzz buzz
listen 11 color did a lot of great
things right they had jim carrey
jamie foxx the wayne bros who else
uh a ton of people jennifer lopez
jennifer lopez she was a dancer on there
but still like that i mean take it easy
no that gave her come on let's also take
it
that gave her a boost they gave her a
platform to hook up with famous people
so yeah
that's not what she was doing she could
have been thought and we don't know
and then she got the role of selena
keena and ivory wayans yeah
come on man this brother's a
[Music]
kelly caulfield was gangster tommy davis
oh he was hilarious grier
yeah dave a lot of real hitters on there
uh i'm starting out live kid man i grew
up on star life
old school saturday night live with
chris farley old school
adam smith adams the past 15 years 10
years though it's been pretty bad 12
years it has been pretty rough but
if we're but look this is in the 90s so
you compare 90 saturn live to 90s in
living color
both great both are great um what i
liked about
in living color was that it also was
like super diverse it was like
i mean half the characters were probably
80 of the characters were black
that's why they made it um
yeah look at this dude look at that
lineup damn i didn't know jay moore was
on saturday live
he didn't get a lot of was he a writer
uh i think he was one of those duo
things but he didn't get a lot of play
i've heard talk about it before
jay moore used to be a comedy beast yeah
but yeah a lot of great lot i got a lot
of real hitters on there man i'm an uh
spade you got
carvey who else go up sandler myers
kneeling
tim meadows damn i mean maybe unique do
you watch any of these shows
i do i love comedy and i gotta say i
really am having a hard time picking a
favorite as well they're both really
great especially these
casts yeah and in mexico like do the do
mexican people like certain types of
comedy or something better than other
types i know
i'd say most latinos were very silly and
we've got
a couple of shows we've got sabo higante
which is definitely it's like
yeah which one is that which one was the
guy with the big uh with the clown hair
or whatever
it's like i did i went on there one time
it's like
that one of the guys has a is a clown he
has like a wig and he's a clown
it's like a talk show i'm not sure it's
pretty ridiculous probably something
your parents would probably watch it's
like an older period oh older
oh yeah who's your like uh as far as
mexican comedians go is like fluffy
the big kind of your guys is uh bill
burr i guess
uh oh he is the most famous one so i
guess
no george lopez complaint
that one have you ever heard of that no
this hella mexican dude
you were on that it's in mexico dude you
go to mexico basically you went to new
york
yeah like you have to go underground and
come up to get there oh my goodness
is it fun yeah
it was pretty fun dude i think it was
yeah fluffy man that's the only one
felipe esparza
felipe is great who else george lopez
oh yeah he's the classic there's not a
lot of and this is a
problem we've actually been having we've
been looking for young mexican comedians
to come on
there's nothing i know some okay there's
maybe two or three
hey jesus trejo jesus trejo frank
castillo renee vaca
um don't don't don't do me wrong now
because i named three
maybe we gotta work harder but we were
also looking for a females correct
malice
now you got that fake mexican uh who's
german
who carlos smith carl's mencia he's
german german yeah
what a piece of [ __ ]
but you know how hard it is to be german
and mexican dude that's probably hard as
[ __ ] i mean are you from honduras or
something he's he said he's
honduran born yeah he's hondura yeah he
also wrote his wikipedia he also stole a
bunch of jokes so
yeah is he even a real comedian he was
raised in east los angeles
uh mitzi's the one that he changed his
real name's ned and mitzi told him to
change it to appeal to mexicans
really yep um his real name was ned
mitzi goes dude if you want to appeal to
mexicans what you're going for yeah
change it to carlos oh a smart move
smart move um i'm going to go with uh
in living color i'm going saturday live
all day the answer is not mad tv